I think Israel wants to continue to
fight because they get justifications
for uh the annexation of the Golan
Heights they get justifications for
expansions especially into area sea that
I that think they're probably going to
try to Annex soon uh they get
justifications for the increased
military posturing uh towards the Gaza
Strip and the embargos and Israel is
right that if the conflict continues
really the situation only improves for
Israel Over time but the Palestinians
also all believe that if they keep
fighting they thought this since 2000
under Arafat that if they just keep
fighting they'll get better gains too
but that's not the case is there a
difference between Palestinian citizens
and the leadership when you say that I
love all people I love all people around
the world and I think that when we
analyze issues I think that we have to
be very honest with what the people on
the ground think and the idea that Hamas
is just this one-off thing in the Gaza
Strip is not only incorrect with the
situation on the ground it's also
incredibly ahistorical um and the idea
that like the Palestinians and the West
Bank of which I believe the most recent
polling shows I want to say 75 to 80%
support the October 7th attacks um
Palestinians in general want to fight in
violent conflict with Israel that's not
just the position of the government
that's not just people there's a reason
why aboss doesn't want to do uh
elections in the West Bank uh and it's
because the Palestinian people really do
want to fight with Israel but to combat
that problem is like you have to get the
UN on board we've got to do an actual
addressing of the Palestinian refugee
problem which is handled like a joke
right now um Iran has to be brought to
the table in terms of negotiation
there has to be huge efforts made to
economically Revitalize these like
Palestinian areas even though they're
one of the highest recipients of Aid in
the world um you have to do something
about the Embargo and the blockade in
the Gaza Strip which isn't just
maintained by Israel it's also
maintained by Egypt you should ask why
um yeah there's a lot of things that
have to happen to fix that problem but
the reality is is I don't think Israel
really wants to because they get to
continue their expansion into the West
Bank and I don't think anybody around
the world really cares that much a month
we won't be talking I will argue with
that the idea that Israel does not want
to end the conflict is be lied by by the
history of what just happened with the
Gaza Strip so when we talk about
settlements for example Israel did have
settlements inside the Gaza Strip there
were 8,000 Jews who were living inside
the Gaza Strip in gush katif uh up until
2005 they they they withdrew all of
those people I mean took them literally
out of their homes uh and the result was
not the burgeoning of a of a better
attitude toward the state of Israel with
regard to for example you know the the
Palestinian population in Gaza in fact
it was more radical in Gaza than it was
in the West Bank uh the the the result
was obviously the election of Hamas the
the October 7th attacks in which
unfortunately many civilians took place
took part in the October 7th attacks
there's video of people rushing who are
civilians and dressed in civilian
clothing into Israeli Villages not
always the same thing well no no that is
that is 100% true obviously uh and when
it comes to you know area sea and
Israel's you know supposed deep in
abiding desire for territorial expansion
in area SE area SE so for for those who
are not familiar with the oso cords and
again this is getting very abstruse but
the oso cords are broken down into three
areas of the West Bank area a is under
full Palestinian control that would be
like Janine and abbl the the major
cities for example there's area B which
is mixed Israeli Palestinian control
where Israel provides some level of
military security and control uh and
then there's area C and area C was like
to be decided later it was left up for
possible concessions to the Palestinian
Authority if the oso cords had moved
forward those are disputed territories
there is building taking place in areas
by both actually no one talks about this
but by by Palestinians as well as
Israelis uh and the the you know
question is to whether if Israel sto
building there have been many settlement
freees in the past including some
undertaken by Netanyahu and and it
actually has not done one iota of good
in moving the ball forward in terms of
actual negotiations again the the
biggest problem is that the leadership
for Palestinians has spent every day
since really' 67 it's not even 48
because after 40 between 48 and 67
Jordan was in charge of the West Bank
and Egypt was in charge of the Gaza
Strip and at no point did either of
those Powers say hey maybe we ought to
hand this over to an independent
Palestinian state which was originally
the division that was that was promoted
by the UN partition plan in
47 because of that uh the the leadership
post 67 and really starting in ' 64 the
Palestine Liberation Organization was
founded in ' 64 and it called for the
liberation of the land in ' 64 they had
the West Bank and they had the Gaza
Strip so they're talking about Tel Aviv
uh when it was founded in in 64 the
basic idea as you know kind of indicated
by that was Israel will exist and that
was a promise that's been made by pretty
much every Palestinian leader in Arabic
to the people that they are talking to
yasat famously would do this sort of
thing he'd speak in English and talk
about how he wanted a two-state solution
and then he'd go back to his own people
and say this is a trojan horse and we're
if Israel could I if you think that
Israeli parents want to send their kids
at the age of 18 to go and monitor
Janine and Nablus and be in inun you're
out of your mind you're out of your mind
Israelis do not want that in fact
Israelis didn't want that so much that
they allowed Rockets to fall in their
cities for full on 18 years in order to
avoid sending soldiers on mass back into
the Gaza Strip true but I think Israel
does want to continue to expand
settlements into the West Bank right
they want to continue to build they want
to have all Jerusalem East Jerusalem as
well well I mean East Jerusalem has
already been annexed so East Jerusalem
is according to Israel a part of Israel
that's not a settlement okay so there
there's that with regard to you know
does Israel have an interest in
expanding settlements in the West B why
would they not until there's a peace
partner sure that's what I mean but I'm
saying as long as the conflict continues
like because even when you talk about no
but your suggestion is that they're in
iing the conflict to continue so they
can grab more land well no let me be
very clear I don't think there's like a
like so some people say for instance
they'll take that one quote from
Netanyahu and they'll try to say that
like he was funding the people in the
Gaza Strip by allowing kariani to come
in even though he was actually speaking
in opposition to abas allowing the Gaza
Strip to fall for Netanyahu to clear it
out for him and they give it back etc
etc I'm not saying I'm not claiming
those theories I'm just saying that I
think that Israel will take a relatively
neutral stance towards conflict enduring
because as long as the conflict endures
and as long as the uh settlements can
expand I think that benefit I think that
ultimately benefits Israel I think there
would be very let's put this way if
suddenly there arose among the
Palestinians a deep and abiding desire
for peace approved by a vast majority of
the population with serious security
guarantees I think you'd be very
hardpressed to find Israelis who would
not be willing to at least consider that
in return for not expanding bathrooms in
a fra I kind of I would have agreed with
you on October 6 I think we're probably
a year or two away from that right now
no no but no but the point I'm making is
that Israelis now realize that the
entire peace process was a sham meaning
the people who are on the other side of
the table we're using it as a trojan
horse in the first place the the death
of Oslo is not the death of Israeli
hopefulness it's the death of the
illusion that on the other side of the
table was anyone worth bargaining with
that's what's happening and that's why
you have this sort of insane disconnect
right now between the United States and
the Israeli government again it's a
Unity government no one in Israel is
talking about making concessions to the
Palestinian Authority for a wide variety
of reasons including the fact that
Mahmud abas fat continues to pay actual
families of terrorists who kill Jews the
fund right and and which is from the the
moderate West Bank right exactly that's
that so yeah again like the taste in
Israel for this is a even the people who
are the right those are the most secular
people in Israel which was by the way
the place that was attacked on October
7th I mean what people should understand
is that October 7th was not an attack
against settlements in the West Bank it
was an attack on peace Villages that
were essentially disarmed and many of
these people who were killed were peace
activists were literally trying to work
with people in Gaza to get them J I mean
it's just it's it's mindboggling that's
why you've had this ground shift in
Israel the next 20 years in Israel is
going to be about security and economic
development period end of story
everything else goes second third place
and I will say I agree essentially with
everything you're saying um not to loop
back another topic but this is one of
the reasons then why I was so critical I
don't want to say critical but like kind
of nonchalant about the Abraham Accord
because they didn't address anything
with the Palestinians whatsoever they
brought countries that weren't super
relevant to the conflict they didn't
bring in Qatar which is where a lot of
the money and support for the god conf
they didn't involve Iran at all they
involved bilateral totally changed the
mentality and this is why what I'm
seeing right now this is why listen I
think that that Biden has done better
than I certainly expected him to do in
terms of support for Israel like Obama
was way less supportive of Israel than
Biden by every metric with that said the
rhetoric that he's been using recently
and the blankin have been using recently
about Israel needs to make painful
concessions for peace Israel reentering
this issue at the center of relations in
the Middle East is doomed to failure the
magic magic is a strong word the the
benefit of the Abraham Accords was proof
of what you're saying which is true
which is that all the surrounding
countries in reality have abandoned the
idea that there's a centrality to the
Palestinian isra conflict that is not
the central conflict in the Middle East
and by the way one of the reasons it's
not the central conflict in the Middle
East is because actually ironically
because of the rise of Iran right it's
it's Sun states that are largely signing
up with Israel because they're realizing
they need some sort of counterweight to
a a burgeoning nuclear power in
Iran